ces ingénieurs du bureau d'études paseo
ont une mission bien précise imaginer et
mettre au point des gabarits en carbone
pour faciliter l'assemblage des pièces
pour les voitures l'intérêt c'est que il
est ultra léger et ultra résistant c'est
à dire qu'en terme de torsion il est
quasiment rien déformable pour un
matériau qui est super légers donc ça
c'est l'intérêt alors qu'auparavant il
ya une dizaine d'années ce moyen de
réglage capot comme ça s'appelle été
fait en aluminium suspendu à tout un
dispositif au dessus de la ligne
d'assemblage des voitures chez ce talent
tisse un bureau d'études implantée à
deux pas de ce thé lantiss à sochaux son
gabarit est utilisé sur la nouvelle
chaîne de production de la 3008 pour
ajuster le montage des pare-chocs et
capot avant
et c'est dans son atelier que les
installer lui aussi dans le pays de
montbéliard que philippe charlot à
développer l'utilisation du carbone un
matériau haut de gamme il travaille
aussi la fibre de verre
voilà c'est tout léger et on est en
résine et chaque opération chaque porte
par exemple ici sera identique et c'est
cette activité de fabrication que
viendra chd et jean baptiste permet le
directeur du bureau d'études belfortain
le client l'avait en aluminium mais le
problème c'est que le bras on va dire
voilà bouger comme ça et manquait de
rigidité et donc le robot ne pouvais pas
accélérer la production ce rachat permet
au bureau d'études de maîtriser la
fabrication des gabarits de a à z de la
conception à l'installation chez le
client on va gagner sur la réactivité
sur l'aspect aussi financier puisque on
a à chaque fois qu'il ya un fournisseur
entre chaque opération il ya forcément
une marge qui s'amoindrit au fur à
mesure donc dans un contexte économique
où les marges rétrécissent et les
constructeurs automobiles cher à cherche
à faire des économies on peut le dire
sur leurs fournisseurs sur leur
équipementier eh bien nous salue nos
stratégies ça a été au contraire de se
rapprocher d'eux pour éviter tous ces
intermédiaires quant à philippe chesneau
il va transmettre son expérience aux
salariés de passer au un savoir faire
qui restera dans le nord francs comptez